new reports say the FBI used a
controversial dossier of alleged
contacts between President Trump and
Russian agents as evidence for a secret
surveillance warrant sources confirmed
to CBS News that the FBI obtained the
dossier full of allegations that Russian
intelligence has compromising
information about the president the
dossier also claimed the Russians had
contact with former Trump campaign
adviser Carter page the FBI later asked
a judge for a so-called FISA warrant to
monitor pages communications he denies
any wrongdoing with us now as
congressman Adam Schiff ranking Democrat
on the House Intelligence Committee
congressman welcome thank you it's good
to be with you this dossier is
controversial do you believe this
dossier well one of the things that we
have to investigate through our
committee is were the issues and
allegations made the dossier accurate to
where some of them accurate we're all
the maket were none of them accurate
that is certainly something we're
looking into it's not really something
frankly I could discuss on this program
but this is a matter of deep interesting
concern for the committee and relevant
oh yes absolutely relevant but but again
we have to see whether it can be
substantiated so when can we expect
another hearing from your committee well
you know happy to report that our
committee is really back on track we
have a new Republican lead Mike Conaway
of Texas I think he's a very serious guy
we've had a number of good conversations
since he took the Republican reins I
think he is quite determined week well
we are in the process of agreeing on the
first crunch of witnesses talking about
scheduling I certainly hope so we are
obviously pushing for that
why wouldn't if you're hoping so why
wouldn't it happen
well it's not my decision alone but I do
think and I've certainly tried to make
this case that it's very important that
our committee not only do what work we
have to do in a closed session but do as
much in open session as we can bring the
public along in the course of the
investigation otherwise if we go on for
months and months and then we suddenly
issue a report I don't think they'll
have the public's confidence if they
haven't seen how we have proceeded with
the investigation so I'm hoping that
where we can we do as much of this as
possible in public do you believe that
when
and Trump's all whatever he saw and said
what he did about President Obama he had
seen something from Susan Rice I think
and you know again I'm speculating about
the president's motives here which is a
very tough thing to do with this
president or probably any other I think
that he was you know looking to make an
accusation against this predecessor to
deflect attention from the issues
involved the rest investigation and then
forced to back it up and may have
dispatched his staff to try to find
something so that certain rights came in
at that point what are you trying to
back it up let's get let's clear that
out because I think it's important not
to malign Susan Rice because there's no
evidence on that that particular charge
in fact Ryan Lizza of The New Yorker
just reported recently undocumented up
we talk about what the president was
acting on yes so Ryan Lizza is reporting
that he spoke with intelligence sources
who said the names of trent's Trump
associates were masked in those
documents that Devon Nunez viewed at the
White House and that you subsequently
viewed at the White House can you
clarify that well I can't go into the
contents of any of the documents but I
can't say I think it was reckless of the
President to make the accusation against
his predecessor that he was illegally
wiretapped by Obama I think it was
reckless of him to accuse Susan Rice of
engaging in some criminality these are
not actions that anyone should do
without evidence and they're not
something that the president states
ought to do in any event level these
kind of accusations so we as a part of
our ordinary oversight look at issues of
minimization of whether names were
masked or unmasked properly we're going
to review all that we were doing that
anyway even before this investigation
but I don't think casually suggesting
people are engaged in the legality makes
sense for anyone to do and least of all
the President of the United States do
you think what noon is dead has tainted
your committee of the committee I think
it cast a real cloud over the committee
and I think he made the right decision
although I'm sure it was a very hard
decision for him to step aside we now
have I think a fresh start and we are
very much back to where we should have
been to begin with before the whole
White House thing so we are scheduling
witnesses we are agreeing on the process
for how we interview them we are
how will request documents we are also
continuing the review of the classified
documents pertinent to the investigation
so all of that is once again proceeding
apace the way it should and I think
we're you know back to restoring the
integrity investigation you also see the
latest information on North Korea
correct yes
Bloomberg is reporting that North Korea
may now possess between ten and twenty
five nuclear weapons and that's on top
of us estimates that they have the
world's largest chemical weapons
stockpiles can you confirm that well I
can't confirm the specifics of it
because that would require me to use
information I have on a classified basis
but I can't say that probably the most
serious national security crisis this
president is going to face is when the
regime gets to the point where it can
miniaturize a nuclear device and put it
on an intercontinental ballistic missile
that point we'll probably come during
this four-year term of the president so
that challenge is coming if something
doesn't change and the key I think here
and I think the president is right about
this the key is China getting China to
really crack down on North Korea's
programs both missile and nuclear thus
far China has only been willing to I
think go through superficial efforts to
do that I think we can't take steps to
press upon China the need to do much
more and it's not going to come from the
president asking nicely or asking uh
nicely I think what it will come with is
an acceleration of the implementation of
theater missile defense a greater naval
presence in the region and telling China
look we're gonna have to pose secondary
sanctions that is sanctions on your
banks for doing business with North
Korea if you don't act these are steps
the Chinese don't want to see happen
they don't want to see a greater
military presence by the u.s. in the
region but if we underscore that we're
gonna have to do this to protect
ourselves and our allies then maybe that
gets China to act is the toughest
problem for North Korea either
developing an ICBM or being able to
minner i miniaturize their nuclear
warheads well I think they're both a
challenge but frankly both a challenge
that they are on the path to overcoming
they're making sufficient progress both
with their nuclear program
and with their missile program that I
think we have to reasonably expect that
they will get there if things don't
change within four years you've said
well I believe so and and prudently I
think we have to expect so it still may
not be enough even if we get China's
help but we need to explore every
diplomatic possibility because I'll tell
you the the military options are all
terrible and it's part of the reason why
I think the president is on very
dangerous ground with all the
sabre-rattling when you said he was
sending in Armada there and that turned
out not to be the case well it turned
out not to be the case which you know is
more than embarrassing because of course
if the provocation of saying that caused
the north to react and we didn't have
our capabilities in the region that
would compound the problem but North
Korea can devastate Seoul South Korea
just with conventional artillery they
don't need to use a nuclear weapon to do
that so this is a very combustible
situation and I think the president
needs to be very careful not to either
explicitly or implicitly draw red lines
he's not prepared to to follow up
putting 30,000 US troops absolutely
hardly one for miscalculation yeah
absolutely
thank you very nice to have you at the
table thank thank you so much